Guatemala es un país que tiene el dudoso
honor de haber sufrido la guerra civil
más larga de toda latinoamérica 36 años
de conflicto hablamos del país más
grande de toda Centroamérica al menos en
términos de población pero también uno
de los más corruptos
rodeado por Honduras Belice y El
Salvador de bukele Guatemala es también
el país centroamericano con la mayor
frontera con México sumergido de una
inmensa naturaleza además de con
volcanes tan imponentes como el de
pacaya el volcán de fuego o el de agua
también nos encontramos la mayor
población indígena de Centroamérica
aproximadamente el 40% de sus 17
millones de habitantes son indígenas es
decir hablamos de cerca de 7 millones de
guatemaltecos lo que lo convierte en el
segundo país de toda latinoamérica con
mayor población indígena tan solo por
detrás de México
[Música]
pero Guatemala no es solo una rica
naturaleza y una gran diversidad
cultural como ya hemos dicho Guatemala
destaca por ser extremadamente corrupto
[Música]
como podéis ver en este ranking
Guatemala es el quinto país más corrupto
de latinoamérica lo cual le sitúa
automáticamente como uno de los 30 más
corruptos del mundo y ya sé lo que me
vais a decir todos venga ya Fonseca un
país corrupto latinoamérica pues menuda
novedad Y sí tenéis razón pero el caso
de Guatemala es especial por una cosa
Guatemala ha hecho un esfuerzo titánico
para luchar contra toda esa corrupción
de hecho si hubiéramos hecho este vídeo
Hace cuatro o cinco años la historia
sería como Guatemala está dejando atrás
su horrible pasado Sin embargo las cosas
han ido a peor para que os hagáis una
idea en 2022 registraron su peor dato
histórico en los rankings de corrupción
dicho de otra forma que vamos de
Guatemala a guatepeor lo siento no he
podido evitar hacer el chiste malo pero
sabéis que es lo más curioso que toda
esta degradación institucional no ha
sido el fruto de ningún Mesías populista
estilo Hugo Chávez ni similares ni
siquiera de una Revolución Esta es una
historia de intereses creados política
de salón y muchísima muchísima impunidad
Así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos
Es como tiantres llegó a Guatemala a ser
un país tan corrupto como quiso Li derar
la lucha contra la corrupción a nivel
mundial y Por qué fracasó este
experimento hasta dónde llegan realmente
los tentáculos de las coimas los sobres
y los sobornos hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
las secuelas de un largo conflicto
Ya sé que usar la expresión de Guatemala
guatepeor es un chiste malo que os voy a
decir pero es que lo cierto Es que
refleja perfectamente la historia de
este país vamos a ser claros casi todos
los países de latinoamérica tienen
historias turbulentas eso es verdad pero
muy pocos llegan al nivel de Guatemala
podríamos decir que desde su comienzo
como país casi todo ha ido a peor
Guatemala se independizó en 1821 de
España dos años más tarde en 1823 se
independizaron de México y desde
entonces este país ha sufrido una serie
de dictaduras o una tras otra desde
Rafael carrera justo después de la
Independencia guatemalteca pasando por
Manuel Estrada Cabrera el general Jorge
ubico o La dictadura comenzada por el
coronel Carlos Castillo armas por
supuesto Guatemala también Tuvo una
etapa comunista hablamos de la
presidencia de Jacobo arbenz presidencia
que terminó con un golpe de estado
apoyado por los Estados Unidos ya sabéis
que durante la Guerra Fría América
Latina fue el patio trasero de
Washington y Guatemala fue una de las
víctimas más damnificadas
[Música]
la llegada en 1954 del gobierno militar
encabezado por Castillo armas supuso La
abolición de las políticas de izquierdas
de Jacobo arbenz y Juan José Arévalo el
ejército suprimió la reforma agraria y
la formación de asociaciones y
sindicatos de campesinos y trabajadores
apenas seis años más tarde en 1960 dio
comienzo la guerra civil que enfrentó al
gobierno militar las patrullas de
autodefensa civil creadas por este
contra varias guerrillas revolucionarias
como la organización del pueblo en armas
o el ejército guerrillero de los pobres
las cuales más tarde crearon el famoso
grupo unidad Revolucionaria nacional
guatemalteca El caso es que Durante los
siguientes 36 años cerca de 200.000
personas perdieron la vida de forma
violenta el 83% de ellas fueron
indígenas de hecho en medio de esta
guerra tuvo lugar Incluso un genocidio
contra los indígenas Maya y shield entre
1981 y 1983 la comisión para el
esclarecimiento histórico conformada en
1997 determinó que cerca del 90% de
todas las violaciones de los derechos
humanos fueron responsabilidad del
estado
y por fin en 1996 llegó el acuerdo de
paz sin embargo desgraciadamente a la
violencia no terminó
de hecho en el año 2006 el número de
homicidios fue casi del doble que en
1996 cuando se firmaron los acuerdos de
paz en el país y la pregunta es cómo es
posible que muera más gente en tiempos
de paz que en tiempos de guerra la razón
se puede resumir con este acrónimo fiax
cuerpos ilegales y aparatos clandestinos
de seguridad es decir organizaciones
criminales creadas por el propio estado
para atacar a las guerrillas Y qué
hacían exactamente Pues en resumidas
cuentas participar en el narcotráfico el
contrabando y otras actividades ilegales
ahora Eso sí con una enorme ventaja el
conocimiento profundo del estado pensad
que muchos de estos grupos tenían
antiguos generales del ejército
oficiales de inteligencia y tenían
contactos en las más altas instancias de
la política guatemalteca sin embargo en
el año 2007 hubo un punto de inflexión
un nuevo Sheriff llegó a Guatemala y
aquí es cuando llega ese momento donde
este país pudo haber cambiado su curso y
diréis qué pasó pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
una comisión Por la honestidad
vamos a ser honestos que nos digan que
los homicidios se han disparado o que
alguien ha sido asesinado en
Latinoamérica Son noticias que ya no
sorprenderá nadie sin embargo en 2007 en
Guatemala pasó algo que rompió todos los
esquemas fijados atentos
Asesinan a tres diputados salvadoreños
en Guatemala
asesinados los policías guatemaltecos
acusados de la muerte de tres diputados
salvadoreños un comando armado entra en
la cárcel donde estaban recluidas las
víctimas y las tirotean después de
degollarlas efectivamente en cuestión de
una semana cuatro policías guatemaltecos
que habían asesinado a tres diputados
salvadoreños fueron asesinados en la
cárcel como os podéis imaginar estos
asesinatos estaban auspiciados por el
propio estado y diréis quién presionó el
gatillo Pues los principales sospechosos
son las ciax es decir estos grupos
criminales auspiciados por los propios
servicios de inteligencia del Estado
Pues bien esta fue la gota que conmó el
vaso a partir de este crimen Guatemala
se embarcó en un experimento único en
materia de seguridad y derechos la
comisión de investigación contra la
impunidad en Guatemala también conocida
como la cicic y quedaos con este nombre
porque es fundamental para entender el
resto de la historia
creada por un acuerdo entre Guatemala y
la ONU en diciembre de 2006 la
importancia de la cicic quedó expuesta
tras los asesinatos de los diputados
salvadoreños y los policías asesinados
en la cárcel en 2007 formada como una
especie de fiscalía su cúpula era
elegida por el secretario general de la
ONU y tenía una autonomía casi absoluta
de hecho la comisión recaudaba sus
propios fondos para evitar la
interferencia de las autoridades de
Guatemala no obstante sus poderes
estaban limitados ya que tenía que
colaborar con el Ministerio Público y la
fiscalía especial contra la impunidad y
los casos que presentaba eran sometidos
al sistema de justicia de guatemalteco
que decidía en última instancia si estos
eran o no juzgados sin embargo la cicic
Sí fue capaz de promover la aprobación
de leyes como la ley del crimen
organizado o las que permitían escuchas
telefónicas de sospechosos
sin embargo seamos honestos Durante los
primeros años de existencia la difick
actuó como se espera que actúe cualquier
cosa que lleve la palabra comisión en el
nombre vamos que no pusieron a los
criminales en ningún aprecio importancia
y Esto fue así hasta el año 2014 Y
diréis qué pasó en ese momento pues que
la citygia eligió a un nuevo comisionado
Iván Velázquez para los colombianos que
ves Este vídeo Sí hablamos de ese Iván
Velázquez el que ahora es vuestro
ministro de defensa y diréis Pero qué
hizo Velázquez para dar un verdadero
impulso la pues lo primero de todo darse
cuenta de que el enemigo estaba dentro
del propio sistema
[Música]
las diacs campaban a sus anchas por
Guatemala porque tenían tentáculos
dentro de las propias instituciones
guatemaltecas y por eso Si queréis
acabar con ellas había que poner el foco
en la lucha contra la corrupción y mis
queridos amigos de visualpolitik aquí sí
empezó a incomodar a mucha gente
importante en Guatemala queréis un
ejemplo pues os doy un ejemplo una de
las mayores tramas de corrupción en la
historia del país el caso de la línea se
una trama de corrupción aduanera
detectada en 2015 que ha tenido
repercusiones hasta finales del 2022
Guatemala 16 años de prisión para el
expresidente Pérez por delitos de
corrupción el expresidente de Guatemala
oto Pérez Molina ha sido condenado a 16
años de prisión y una multa de un millón
de dólares por delitos de corrupción
Pérez está en prisión desde 2015 acusado
de liderar una red de defraudación
aduanera en el caso conocido como la
línea y no solo eso su ex vicepresidenta
Roxana valdetti también fue sentenciada
el pasado de diciembre a la misma
condena por los mismos cargos pero
Velázquez no se detuvo ahí después de
darse cuenta de lo tremendamente
enredadas que estaban las redes de
corrupción su siguiente objetivo fue
Jimmy Morales Y diréis quién es este
hombre Quién es el bueno de Jimmy
Morales Pues nada menos que el
presidente de Guatemala por aquel
entonces presidente hasta el año 2020 y
vaya si le encontraron casos lo primero
un caso menor de corrupción en los que
el hermano y el hijo del presidente
estaban involucrados pero fue solo el
comienzo aún más importante fue el caso
de financiación legal del partido frente
de convergencia nacional cuando Morales
era su secretario general y era también
el candidato a la presidencia por esta
plataforma y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos un aplauso al Señor
Velázquez Y la verdad fueron el
auténtico látigo de los corruptos Y sí
tenéis razón pero incomodar a los
poderosos tiene un problema a los
poderosos no les gusta que les incomoden
y al presidente Morales no le hizo la
más mínima gracia que aparecieran todos
estos escándalos de corrupción Así que
ese fue el principio del fin de la fifí
tras ser acusado de financiar
ilegalmente su Campaña en la presidencia
Morales no tardó en tomar represalias
contra la fifig la presidencia le retiró
el apoyo a la comisión que tanto estaba
siendo lavada por la comunidad
internacional el Ministerio de la
gobernación la procuraduría y otras
instituciones y organismos que habían
estado colaborando con lacific dejaron
de res paldarla de hecho Incluso se le
vetó la entrada al comisionado Velázquez
después de que este salida del país en
un viaje oficial finalmente el
presidente Morales se negó a revalidar
el mandato de la cicic lo que llevó a su
disolución en 2019
Y sí habéis oído bien la bicis murió
Pese a que el 70% de los guatemaltecos
la apoyaban de hecho la disolución de
esta comisión resonó en toda la
comunidad internacional atentos la
decisión unilateral del presidente Jimmy
Morales de dar por terminado en un plazo
de 24 horas el acuerdo de creación de la
cicic anunciada en Nueva York por la
ministra joven es una señal más del
progresivo rompimiento institucional y
el estado de derecho Rigoberta menchú
guatemalteca Premio Nobel de la paz de
1992 sin embargo muchas otras voces
también festejaron la decisión del
presidente al considerar que la se había
extralimitado en sus funciones y que
Guatemala estaba perdiendo su soberanía
la fue apoderando del sistema de
justicia y la poca confianza que había
en los jueces desapareció por culpa de
la fifí José Luis González dubón miembro
de la liga propatria de Guatemala 2019
sea como sea Ya estuvieran A favor o en
contra de la fifí los guatemaltecos se
enfrentaban a una nueva realidad una
Guatemala sincid después de 12 años en
los que se había dejado en evidencia el
gran entramado corrupto en el que viven
buena parte de la clase política y
empresarial del país y como os podéis
imaginar tiene esta comisión todos los
corruptos volvieron a sus prácticas
habituales con total impunidad Guatemala
volvió a ser guatepeor y os preguntaréis
En qué estado se encuentran en estos
momentos Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
retomando viejos hábitos
si algo nos han enseñado estos últimos
cuatro años que Guatemala ha estado sin
es que los avances en la lucha contra la
corrupción pueden desvanecerse en un
abrir y cerrar de ojos en 2019 los
guatemaltecos eligieron al sucesor del
ya entonces impopular presidente morales
y así es como Alejandro yamatei fue
elegido nuevo presidente de la república
Y diréis qué ha hecho este hombre pues
ha iniciado una persecución contra
muchos de los jueces y Fiscales que
lucharon contra la corrupción hombro a
hombro con la oficina
esta persecución tiene un protagonista
Rafael curruchiche actual jefe de la
fiscalía especial contra la impunidad
del Ministerio Público fue designado por
la fiscal general Consuelo porras que a
su vez le debe su revalidación en el
puesto a yamatei a la que por cierto
Estados Unidos ha señalado como un actor
corrupto curruchiche que lo primero que
hizo fue archivar Las investigaciones
abiertas contra yamatei se lanzó en
tromba a perseguir a los investigadores
de la cifij y de la propia fiscalía que
habían abierto casos contra políticos y
empresarios del país por ejemplo
órdenes de captura contra Telma Aldana
exfiscal general y una de las juristas
más reconocidas contra la corrupción que
vive hoy en el exilio o también contra
David Gaitán exfuncionario de la cicic
que trabaja hoy con la ong transparencia
internacional de hecho a finales de mayo
del presente año 2023 capturaron al
fiscal estuardo campo ex jefe de la
fiscalía anticorrupción que persiguió
por la vía penal al expresidente morales
y Que investigó a diferentes ministros
del gobierno y a jueces involucrados en
diferentes casos de corrupción
pero ojo no solo ha perseguido a
Fiscales y a jueces la prensa también ha
sido la víctima de esta venganza atentos
persecución contra la prensa el
periódico de Guatemala anuncia su cierre
ante el acoso del gobierno el fundador
de la publicación José Rubén Zamora
lleva casi 10 meses en prisión después
de décadas denunciando casos de
corrupción Estatal por lo que vemos el
odio hacia los medios de comunicación en
Centroamérica no entiende de ideologías
en El Salvador con bukele tenemos al
periódico El Faro en el punto de mira
del gobierno Ortega en Nicaragua que es
de izquierdas ha hecho lo mismo con el
periódico La Prensa y bien en el caso de
Guatemala yamatei que es de ideología
conservadora también tiene un periódico
en la Diana en este caso es el periódico
[Música]
conclusión sólo entre 2018 y 2023 30
personas entre las que hay jueces
Fiscales y periodistas han tenido que
huir del país y bueno uno podrá decir
vale pero mientras vivan bien Que más da
que haya corrupción y sois veteranos
seguidores de visualpolitik ya sabéis lo
que vamos a decir ahora el desarrollo de
un país está ligado a la calidad de sus
instituciones En otras palabras que un
país corrupto tiene todas las papeletas
para ser increíblemente pobre y el caso
de Guatemala no es una excepción para
que os hagáis una idea en 2020 el 59% de
los 17 millones de guatemaltecos se
encontraban en situación de pobreza y en
2023 apenas se espera que se reduzca
hasta el
55%. además como podéis ver esta pobreza
pega Mucho más duro a las comunidades
indígenas y a Las campesinas que también
suelen estar dominadas por los propios
indígenas Y es más la pobreza es tal que
según el Banco Mundial el 47% de todos
los niños menores de 5 años sufren de
desnutrición y os estaréis preguntando
Pero cómo puede ser que todo esto sea
posible Pues bien la mayoría de los
analistas lo suelen achacar a tres
factores
[Música]
en primer lugar el acceso a la tierra ya
desde el siglo XIX con el Boom de la
producción de café en el país se
desarrollaron una serie de leyes sobre
la propiedad de las tierras y estas
leyes llevaron a una expropiación masiva
de las tierras comunales que pertenecían
a los pueblos indígenas pero no solo eso
en Guatemala todavía sobrevive una
práctica colonial donde los campesinos
no cobran un sueldo habéis oído bien en
este caso muchos grandes terratenientes
no pagan en dinero sino que le dan una
pequeña parcela de tierra del Campesino
para que pueda cultivarla y sobrevivir
de esta forma el campesino no tiene
alternativas para intentar cambiar de
vida sin embargo otras analistas se
centran más en el estado guatemalteco y
a su reducido tamaño debido a la pobre
recaudación tributaria de hecho
Guatemala es el tercer país que menores
impuestos recauda de toda la región solo
por detrás de Panamá y de Paraguay y
diréis claro es que a Guatemala es un
paraíso fiscal pues no para nada ya les
gustaría El problema es que en Guatemala
no tienen impuestos bajos lo que les
pasa es que no saben cómo recaudarlos
Por qué dos razones incompetencia y
corrupción en cualquier caso realmente
cambiaría algo si recaudasen más dinero
pues probablemente no recordad que
hablamos de un país absolutamente
corrupto es decir que poco de ese dinero
iría a pagar escuelas y carreteras dicho
de otra forma que Guatemala es un país
que parece condenado a la Pobreza por
culpa de las élites políticas que lo
gobiernan tuvo una oportunidad de romper
con toda esta lógica pero sus propios
políticos hicieron todo lo posible por
arruinarla y es francamente difícil
pensar que unas elecciones vayan a
cambiar nada pero dicho esto la pregunta
ahora es para vosotros qué creéis que le
hace falta a Guatemala para poder atacar
esta corrupción llegará a organizar otra
comisión como la situación se vuelve aún
más insostenible hay alguna razón para
tener algo de esperanza en este país
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]